pooja Kumar and my twitter handle is
pooja Kumar NY and you can go to pooja
Kumar in suite come with us and as a
director to work with how would he give
you notes and feedback him as a director
I mean as simply as fantastic you know
he he seamlessly transitions between an
actor the director the producer which
has been absolutely fantastic so for me
it was really sort of humbling
experience because he explained
everything so sort of like very
peacefully
and he's very intimidating person so
when you first meet him you're sort of
scared because he's a man who's done
over 200 movies you want to basically
you know impress it
sort of strive for excellent so you're
nervous you know the beginning and then
slowly you know as you meet him he sort
of calms you down and because he wants
you to do so well you actually step
outside your own comforts which i think
is a rare quality and i think it's kind
of a great director yeah how similar is
your character in the film to the way
you are in real life and what are the
differences but I wonder if he to cast
me based on you know it's a visual
medium and I think I've identify with
nirupama unlike so many levels and I
play a scientist Shizuka
and you know I've always I've liked
science all my whole life so I had that
sort of you know kind of closest to that
and you know she's sort of been secure
about who she is then I think initially
as we all like as were younger
we're a little insecure about who we are
and as the girl dur we become so
insecure with what what was in skin
religion and I think that's what her
character is about - if that she's
initially sort of insecure about who she
is and then slowly slowly she
transitions into this woman that sort of
becomes looking becomes confident but it
has a little bit of quirkiness with so
I'm kind of like that - you think that
makes her more likable so people aren't
as intimidated by her so you know and
you know comes to write such a beautiful
female character you know whether it's
one line or five lines or ten nine you
write such beautiful and powerful roles
for them so I think that's why you know
sort of you brings in the quirkiness she
brings them as Hartnett she brings in
you know something that I think everyone
can identify in Indian cinema cinema
excuse me is so exuberant
about their actors and actresses it's
almost like they are actual royalty
where's the thing American cinema is a
little bit different do you feel a great
responsibility to the people of India to
share things that I mean I know there's
so much on websites and it's a lot you
know in Indian cinema is becoming very
popular because I think the music the
fashion literature and so I think you
know we definitely have a duty and I
think if we don't sort of inspire people
or expand the knowledge then we're doing
ourselves a disservice and lastly
because the film is banned for a few
weeks in India what do you have to say I
think Salman Rushdie said it was a
cultural emergency because this film is
is held back about the situation you
know the movie is something that we
should all we're artists we live in a
democracy we live in a free world we
should be
able to show anything that we feel
strongly about and I'm really sad that
people would go against someone
who is a man who is for the people he
has always fought for human rights he
fights for people whether they're Muslim
or Christian or Hindus it doesn't matter
so it's making me very angry and very
sad at the same time so I think if we
all should pull together and show the
support it'll make a big difference
great thank you so much we should